las tensiones en el seno de la coalición
gobernante en italia han alcanzado un
nuevo pico los días de conversaciones
para salvar las diferencias entre el
primer ministro conté y uno de los
partidos claves en la coalición han
fracasado ambas partes han estado
discutiendo sobre como el país debería
gastar los miles de millones de euros
del paquete de estímulo contra el cob y
19 ahora el ex primer ministro matteo
renzi líder del partido viva italia dice
que está preparado para marcharse un
movimiento que podría acabar con el
gobierno de conte
no seremos cómplices el ejemplo más
descarado del mal uso de fondos públicos
en la historia de italia si queremos
avanzar necesitamos tener un plan bajo
una presión creciente con te ha
reescrito el plan de recuperación
doblando la financiación tanto para el
sistema sanitario como para el turismo y
aumentando el porcentaje de inversiones
sin embargo rehn si no cede y amenaza
con la posible renuncia de ministros
procedentes de su formación en respuesta
el primer ministro podría tratar de
remodelar su gabinete o presentar su
dimisión para buscar una rápida
reelección al frente de un nuevo
gobierno si esto fracasa el presidente
mataré la podría ser forzado a disolver
el parlamento y convocar nuevas
elecciones una opción que podría desatar
el caos político mientras italia
continúa luchando contra el kobe 19 que
ha dejado casi 80 mil muertos en el país